the circuit de Barcelona is the venue
for the season final of the sea at Lyon
eurocup the one made touring car series
began in two thousand eight competitors
Dr C at Leone's with two liter
4-cylinder turbo engines the season
comprises seven race meetings with two
races at each meeting each race is 50 to
60 kilometers last year's winner paul
rozelle is expecting the final to be
tough I think this the championship is a
is a great championship there are a lot
of drivers the main drivers are very
competitive aggressive all of them want
to want to win so it is very difficult
arrive in the bottom if you want to stay
in the podium you have to fight paul
rozelle of spain in norway sty and
paulson were running neck and neck with
72 points each as they started the final
race for the title
three men from Germany have come to
watch the final they're actually
professional actors but their dream is
to have a career in racing professional
racecar driver Sebastian style says he
knows they've all earned their basic
racing license but that's just the start
he suggests they all go watch the race
on this great track tom beck has already
had some experience with a real racing
car he trained under Sebastian style to
get his initial license
it's what they ought meet up tom says
one of his first training sessions was
driving a cup racer finding himself
alone on the track where the cup racer
was probably a once-in-a-lifetime
experience and pretty cool and then he
did his license in mending Germany
that's far too much cooler Anton and
many still attends komatsu Seemandhra
has also done a few rounds on the
racetrack with Sebastian on the
legendary Nurburgring north loop no less
damn you d so they have their first
basic license they know what the
different flags mean and a few other
things now they need to start qualifying
for small races so they need to compete
and be among the first five to finish
the race then they get their extended
license and so they work from race to
race and series two series which of
course become increasingly international
and get various licenses until at some
stage they hopefully get a top license
and then they can take part in the
really really big races in fellas nalla
paiyan soda machine intense vista Sudan
Obama went to Vegas old and it sensible
Baba Yaga transpose identified Garrett
Klein has also received training from
Sebastian style he says acting and
racing it more in common than you'd
think they both involve concentration so
Garrett feels well prepared I think he
says he's learned how to study the
racetrack Sebastian looks at everything
closely he studies each bend in the
track and asked what speed does he need
going into which Bend Garrett says
acting is no different he prepares his
roles thinks his way into his character
time will tell whether Tom's Iman and
Garrett have a future in professional
motorsport in the meantime they can
learn plenty at events like this they
watch Poole rusel successfully defend
his title in Barcelona and hope that one
day they could be in his place